this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice ken coleman is my co-host today
here on the ramsey show ramsey
personality best-selling author and
author of the brand new book that
launches tomorrow
from paycheck
to
purpose the clear path to doing work you
love now ken if a book launches tomorrow
that means today
is the last day to get all the bargains
that's right and we've put out quite a
bargain i mean first of all 20 bucks uh
is your entry point for this at
ramseysolutions.com
and then we're going to give you the
ebook the audiobook read by me plus over
a hundred dollars in other tools like
our resume templates uh a video course
that teaches you how to get hired how to
beat the competition right now dave we
have the biggest demand in employee
talent we've ever seen and it is
competitive and so that's a course that
comes with that purchase all a part of
that 100 plus of free items so we are
certainly uh bribing but it's one of the
greatest bribes of all time
55 of americans are looking for a new
job right now
and if you want to stand out in that sea
of talent
passion and experience
uh you have to be very very clear yeah
and ken has the process to do that from
paycheck to purpose one of the things
some of you discovered during the uh
aforementioned pandemic
was that life's too short to spend your
life doing things you suck at or you
hate
and or both
and so people are leaving stuff where
they're not ain't good at it they're
leaving stuff where they hate their
toxic environment they're sick of it
they want to move on they want to do
something with meaning and from paycheck
to purpose helps you do that in the
title it tells you that so yeah that's
the whole process by the way we're
giving you both we want you to have a
fatter paycheck and and experience more
purpose and yet dave in that ramsey it's
not either or it's not either it's both
and it's not like i have to live my
purpose but i'm going to work at a
nonprofit for ten percent of what i can
make somewhere else no that's just
that's exactly right and this idea that
i can't make a really good living doing
something that i care deeply about it's
a process and we unveil that path
interesting dave in the ramsey solutions
work study the full study will come out
first of the year that 55 of americans
looking for a new job right now that's
one little piece of data from this study
another piece is that 64 of those
americans
that are actually 64 percent are saying
i want to move but i'm not sure
where to move and again this book
provides the clarity that key word there
clear path is this isn't just grab your
machete and go we're going to point you
on the right path and show you how to do
it even if by the way you're working
through the baby steps a lot of people
certainly in in the ramsey solutions
tribe go okay i definitely want to work
on purpose but i'm paying off debt well
there are multiple maybe you can change
more money get a bigger shovel as a
result of this and get out of debt
faster so twenty dollars for the book
today's the last day that you get a
hundred dollars worth of bonus tools
like resume templates guides video
courses
all kinds of goodies included in the
audiobook the e-book everything in there
it's it's a deal
today is the last day from paycheck to
purpose by ken coleman number one
best-selling author esmeralda is going
to start off this hour in fresno hi
esmeralda how are you
hi guys i'm ready to talk to both of you
better than i deserve what's up okay so
i'm kind of like correctional nurse and
um
i get paid pretty well for what i do
just because of the environment that i
work in
um and my goal is to become a school
nurse which actually got the position
and i should start soon
but i'm definitely going to take a pay
cut just because of the change of
environment and this is something that
i've been wanting to do for a very long
time because i'm just
stressed and overwhelmed and the
environment is just not the best to work
at
but
my
question is whether this is a good move
right now financially just because i
will be taking a pay cut how big of a
pay cut
it's about
fifteen thousand dollars a year what do
you make now
i make a hundred okay and you're going
to cut to 85 and be a school nurse is
that what you said yes but then in about
two to three years i'll be back at 100.
okay well let's talk about what the next
two to three years looks like before
that so where does that put you are you
single income double income
um
double income my husband makes about 120
so
that's why he's not worried and he's
like you need to go for this if this is
something that you really want to do
because we're we have about
40 000 in debt so he's willing to buckle
down and pay all that off that's awesome
well have a 200 000 income between the
two of you sure so this is not it's just
more me and being scared of like hey you
know i went to school and got my r in
and i wanted to make 100 and i think
it's just more me taking like
the drawback of taking the pay cut yeah
can i suggest to you esmerelda it may
not be just you
part of this i wonder i wonder if you're
worried about what other people might
say or are already saying when you go
from rn and this you know that's
obviously a very prestigious role and
moving into school nurse i wonder how
much of that is coming from what you
think other people might think or say
i think
i don't think it's i think it's just me
if i had a goal of making a certain
amount and how i am and with overtime
here that the potential is limitless but
also i'm concerned with my mental health
and obviously a little bit of safety
because it's getting a little out of
control in here at times i would say
well esmeralda you just laid out
multiple reasons you answered your own
question as to why this is the right
move all of those negatives are
absolutely confirmation that you need to
move but the biggest confirmation is
that you've longed for this you said
i've wanted to do this for a long time
your husband is on board that's a
fantastic position to be in financially
this is not going to be that big of a
hit you're still going to pay off that
debt
and you're going to be happy and you're
going to be fulfilled
and i understand where you're coming
from but you need to give yourself a
break because you have in fact achieved
that goal but what's great is you now
realize that that goal doesn't match up
with your heart and you got to follow
your heart here esmeralda step into this
this is a great move there's nothing
wrong with this move this is the right
move what's the uh what's the worst case
scenario you take the new job
and you get over there
and you hate it
and 20 seconds later you can be an rn
again in a hospital
oh no yeah i can find it so you're not
this is not a part this is not like uh
you've burned all the boats and you
can't go back home
you know
so you you can do whatever you want to
do go try it
and if it doesn't work go back to being
an rn in a less toxic environment some
place some other hospital some other
situation would be an rn at the school i
know but i'm saying go back into the
medical world rather than the school
nurse world
and um if you don't like it if you like
it you know it it this is a no
lose scenario yeah because you you can
in the world that you live in you can
get another job in 26 seconds if you
decide you don't want to be a school
nurse anymore after a year so do it
absolutely go
do it esmerelda yes that's exactly the
way this works guys so what ken does
every day on the ken coleman show if you
want to talk careers we'll do that you
wanna talk money we'll do that the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five
five or we'll talk about your mama
you're right in front of you if you want
me to whatever you want to talk about
we're here it's that simple the book is
from paycheck to purpose the clear path
to doing work you love on the streets
tomorrow last day today of the pre-sale
at ramseysolutions.com
with all the goodies get it while the
gettin's good
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
do
[Music]
welcome to the ramsey show common sense
for your dollars and cents
in a culture where common sense is so
rare that if you have it it's like
having a superpower
ken coleman and i are here to help you
with your life your money your career
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five
five two two five
devin is calling us from japan well
there you go hi devin
hi dave i'm looking for um
short-term housing for about two months
out of the year
when we come home
come back to the states in the summer
time my wife is a teacher
and in the sun and i'm a retired
military
so in the summers when we come home we
need a place to stay for about two
months
and uh we don't own property right now
and with the way the market is right now
is i don't see
when that could actually happen
but should we buy a house or is there a
good way to find i didn't think so and i
was really warm to that i've tried
airbnb
but um airbnb just seems really
overpriced to me
so i'm looking are there any other
alternatives to that
um there's some corporate housing stuff
out there in the hotel world where
somebody's coming to town to work and
it's like a corporate suite thing it's
not necessarily the best in the world
but i would probably prefer an airbnb or
a vacation setting of some kind
and it just depends you know what i've
done on uh not airbnb but on vacation
housing is uh and i did it not long ago
i negotiated with the owner i said
listen i'm not gonna be there for a week
and i'm not gonna be there for a weekend
i'm gonna be there for a month
now
you don't have to change anything out
you don't have the labor you don't have
the turnover you don't have somebody
tearing up your stuff
this was a luxury property i'm going to
be there a month i didn't stay the whole
month but sharon did so uh i had to come
back and work but anyway so we we rented
the thing
and it was in effect like an airbnb type
thing there's a luxury
uh uh vacation rental and uh i just
negotiated with a guy now i gotta tell
you the first three people we went at
said no we went full price and i said
well you're not the one then
and uh because guess what there's three
more down the street and i'm going down
the street down the street down the
street until i find one and i think
that's what you're looking for so you
may have to get something that's not
your first choice
but i think you shop around in that
world and you go at it with this is a
two-month deal it's not a weekend rental
and you should get a different reaction
if you put your shoes on the other feets
what i was doing i was saying i mean put
the put where are the other guys
moccasins if i had a vacation rental up
i would do a deal that way sure yeah
because i'm getting some i don't have to
screw with it right and somebody's not i
don't have the wear and tear of
three bachelorette parties versus a
stable family
you know coming in and out of there
which nothing will tear up a house like
a frat or a bachelorette party they'll
just tear up anything right so wild yeah
crazy
yeah it just depends here on his
situation too where he's staying where
they're coming in do they have any
community where they come back to for a
small amount of time and putting the
word out too
i wouldn't overlook the idea of like
putting the word out saying hey here's
our situation you know rates can be
really high on these vacation homes yeah
some local pastors if your mom and dad
are in a church in that market or your
brother's in a church in that market
tell them check with their pastor and
say hey my you know my brother you know
they he served his wife's a teacher and
uh by the way thank you for your service
yes absolutely and uh that's the best
idea i got dude off top of my head uh
that and you can check some corporate
housing uh uh the those things are
typically not as
good a property as a good
vacation rental
a good one
rick is with us rick is in houston texas
hi rick welcome to the ramsey show
and so i recently lost my job i was on a
step 3d so i had 10 000 in my savings
for my emergency fund and uh 17
in my separate savings i was saving up
for a house fund
if i need to start pulling from
my savings before i'm able to land
another job should i be pulling from the
house fund and and leave the emergency
fund alone or should i be pulling from
the emergency fund itself
i don't think it matters because you
could rename either one of them at the
drop of a hat right
well i guess i didn't think of that yeah
it's just twenty seven thousand dollars
we've got between us and problems
and so um but i i probably
philosophically would start with the
house fund uh here's the thing though i
really don't want you to tap it at all
when did you lose your job
friday from what why
um there was a training incident
i was training a guy and and there was
an undercharge in one of the units and
you know they terminated both of us okay
all right what kind of work are you
looking for
uh i'm a process operator in the
chemical field okay
uh in your area of houston texas i'm
assuming you've done a cursory check
what kind of jobs are open is there a
lot out there or is it a little bit
tougher
yeah typically they do the most hiring
in the spring but there's a few here and
there that'll hire uh at this time of
year it's just uh
you know well and they probably are
short-handed right now right you
probably got some people that that
normally would hire in the spring but
they've got some empty seats yeah
right what kind of money were you making
um i was at a
base salary at 95 000. yeah you know i'm
with dave on don't touch it at all and
i'll tell you why wall street journal
headline over the weekend uh
companies that said something to the
fact of no experience
no education no background check
required that was the headline and
that's where companies are right now and
we're talking about big time companies
and so i just think that the market is
so hot in the interim while you're
applying and you're making the
connections and getting interviews uh i
mean dude you could be making somewhere
between 15 and 20 an hour uh just to
kind of keep things going i just
wouldn't touch that account i don't
think you need to i think you're going
to start making some money by friday
yeah and uh while you look for this job
and i think you'll land a job in two
weeks so i don't think you're gonna end
up touching it but you can make 15 20 an
hour doing almost anything right now
because there's such a hurt in the
market yeah
and so it may not be what you want to do
but rather mess up your house fund is
what i want to do sit on my butt at home
and mess up the house fund no i'll go
i'll go do something else something
unpleasant that i didn't really sign up
for
until this gets solved but i think
you're going to land something if you'll
get on this really really fast so ken um
the first thing he should do in his job
hunt
is what first thing i want him to do is
look at what's open out there and then
he immediately goes okay who do i know
i'm looking at the connection
because he's got experience and skill
yeah okay and so he's immediately going
all right company xyz abc are both
hiring a position i'm ready to go who do
i know over there so i can fast track
and get above the applicant system and
what i mean by that is you know somebody
rick and they say all right yeah man
i'll put in a good word for you i work
in building b the guy who's hiring is
over in building a i'll walk your resume
over and put a handwritten note on it if
they're not in their office and go hey
i've known rick for 18 years that's the
play here and then
then you go through the applicant system
but you want to have a good impression
before you ever get into that and they
go okay we're going to fast track an
interview for rick that's what we're
trying to do first get your foot in the
door and you gotta know somebody to get
in and get past the 30 000 resumes in a
stack yeah and um the book he's
referring to the concept he's referring
to is the proximity principle it was the
number one bestseller rick i'm going to
send you that and i'm also going to give
away my very first copy that i gave away
from paycheck to purpose the clear path
to doing work you love so i'm going to
send you both of ken's books the new one
will be a bestseller as well
and then i want you to also i'm going to
send those to you kelly's going to pick
up and give you the stuff
but go to his website and download all
of his free downloads on resumes on
letter writing on the things you do to
get your foot in the door do not just go
apply for 8 000 positions at monster.com
and be surprised nobody called you back
that's a that's a fool's errand right
now yeah and let me tell you why that
advice that i gave is also so vital in
this situation doesn't sound like
there's an ethical issue here but the
fact of the matter is rick was
terminated uh and yet we still have a
super hot market and people are okay
with that if you own it don't try
to do a politician spin on this stuff if
it comes up own it uh own it with
confidence humility i learned from this
is a good thing i totally get it don't
throw the old company under the bus
here's how i can help you win i'm ready
to go don't ever try to just kind of
cover that stuff up well when i asked
him he gave the perfect answer he gave a
great emotion it was not throwing the
other company on the bus he was not a
victim that's very clear very concise
and that's the exact answer he ought to
give up front in any initial interview
so that no one uh catches later and goes
well why don't you tell us about this
now tell them right up front bust that
down and move on move on move on move on
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's
slash
betheltech.net
coleman
[Music]
so
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage kyle and brenda are with
us hey guys how are you good how are you
welcome where do you guys live delano
minnesota just outside of minneapolis
wow and all the way to nashville to do a
debt free scream how much have you paid
off
572 000.
383.41 cents wow how long did that take
seven years and two months all right and
your range of income during that seven
years two months yeah it was about 110
to 200 and currently we're about 140.
okay cool what do y'all do for a living
uh brenda's a stay-at-home mom and i am
a reporting analyst for a large health
insurance company cool
well uh i'm guessing by the length of
time and the huge amount of money you
paid off your house yup
look at that weird
and we also own a third of a lake home
too so one and a third houses i guess
technically all right all debt-free a
hundred percent death don't owe a soul
in the freaking world nope nope way to
go guys look at these weird people
these are weird people right here man
you guys are amazing congratulations
what a seven year journey that's
absolutely cool yeah all right tell us
the story how'd you get on our stuff for
seven years
yeah when our second child was we knew
they were on the way we put in our
spreadsheet that was less than accurate
and optimistic at best and the number
was actually negative so we knew that we
had to do something we didn't have
enough money to pay for daycare for our
second child and so we naturally i think
we went on facebook and then
when the teach where one of the students
ready the teacher will appear and
someone posted something about it
bought the total money makeover and i
persuaded brenda to
uh join joining the joining the fun so a
lot of persuading
i'm glad he did
okay so he reads this book and says uh
uh we can't pay for daycare which you
already knew yeah but this is uh what
we're gonna do is live on beans and rice
rice and beans live like no one else so
later we can live and give like no one
else and you said i don't think so yeah
well i it took a lot of convincing to
you know the slow steps of you want me
to cut up my credit card you want me to
do what what if something happens being
a mom having all those insecurities and
then we just went for it and we went
crazy and everybody calls us crazy you
are crazy
you're wonderfully weird
i love it wonderfully weird so what did
he do that finally convinced you brenda
what did you do i don't i don't know it
was i think just staring down the
the
just staring down that we had no other
choice i don't know what else to do so i
got to try this crazy right
right and he's my partner and i trust
him and so we just went for it okay and
then the more it worked the more you
thought this is smart right right right
we got after it pretty quick i mean and
i was able to
quit my job and take care of our kids
before our third was born
we bought a brand new vehicle with cash
and it did all that before we even
started to attack attack the house in
the mortgage so how fast did you get out
of the non-mortgage debt it was a little
over two years like exactly what your
numbers were are normal
yeah two years to do that seven years
pay off the house yeah yep and the car
she's talking about was a sweet minivan
so she might have left that part out
a sweet minivan let's just go ahead and
call it what it is sweet so brenda you
said something a minute ago and i think
this is this is really good i'd love for
for for moms and wives to hear what you
say about this when he first approached
you about this you were like wait a
second i got to cut up the credit cards
what if something happens implying that
you saw those credit cards as a safety
net and i understand that
and yet here you are now so what would
you say
uh which is a natural kind of that
mother you know like hey i got to take
care i'm a mama bear yeah
on the other side of this what would you
say to somebody who's listening and
watching right now and they feel the
same way about this journey what i gotta
cut up their credit cards that's our
safety net what's the answer to that now
go get the scissors
i don't know it just is it's just you
um but can you have a safety net without
credit cards is michael oh absolutely
yes i've never even thought about
getting a credit card you absolutely can
so how did you approach that emotionally
as you started to walk through that
because you cut them up and then how did
you address that safety issue that
emotional need yeah that's a good
question i just trusted the process and
knew that it was there for me and it was
there to catch me as long as i put my
trust in them
because here you are seven years later
with a paid for house
what's this house worth
it's probably 250 yeah something like
that we got we got real crazy we
actually downsized our house
in order to be debt-free sooner you
introduced us to the minimalist then we
gave away all our stuff and then we
realized we don't really need the big
house that we're in before and
opportunity came in that we were able to
get my grandma's house and we downsized
everybody thought we were nuts and two
years later no here we are yeah a lot of
people thought you were nuts but uh
you're not you're you're on your way to
being baby steps millionaires in no time
i think so well done guys actually we
already are yeah you already are yeah
all right so how much in the 401k
uh it's probably like six it's like 600
and then the house and cabins 400
something so it's
plus our mini vans probably still worth
10. that sweet minivan
that's your wealth building break for it
through the sweet minivan way to go guys
oh thanks i love it well you did
everything in order you did it right you
submitted to the process and guess what
the process worked yep so you're not
only debt free house and everything baby
step seven but your baby steps
millionaires as well white way to go i'm
so proud of y'all what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
what we were saying about the budget and
how that's cliche so we we were to pull
up the minimalist card and just say like
just keep an open mind and try to listen
to what other people are doing and just
keep learning and
it once you get going it just snowballs
and it's just rapid pace and
next thing you know you look back and
seven years later and you're done yeah
what about you bro what do you tell
people the key is
um
the key is and definitely the budget but
two i think like the deprogramming of
what the world has told us that we need
to have b
and how
all of a sudden you look back you're
like wait i don't need all this stuff i
don't need this house i don't need these
things i just
need my life
i love it wow hey we got to send this to
joshua
they will love that joshua and ryan they
will love this yeah that's really great
we had dinner with them last time they
were here up in my house and hung out we
had some great conversations until deep
in the morning they're they're
incredible guys so well done you guys
i'm so proud of you very very very cool
and you brought the kiddos with you to
celebrate really good what are their
names and ages drew is nine will is
gonna be seven and reid turned five on
sunday all right very cool and have they
been uh they've been plugged into what
you're doing oh yeah they know that
their lives are changed they do there's
no payments in your world
none ever again
i love it way to go you guys very very
very cool well we've got a copy of the
legacy journey for you because that's
definitely the next chapter in your
story as you continue this baby steps
millionaire journey and i'll give you an
extra copy of total money makeover to
give away maybe you can start somebody
off like you guys started off on that
same book that sounds good and that's
how you got here well done you guys very
proud of you whoo i love it so man this
is these people are weird they're
awesome they're awesome all right kyle
and brenda drew will and reed from the
minneapolis area 572
000 paid off in seven years making 110
to 200 house and everything
baby steps millionaires count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream three two
one
[Music]
[Applause]
man oh man oh man
can when you have a clear path and the
stuff she said we we i love the phrase
uh submit to the process
she said she said uh uh
deprogram program from the culture big
word because the culture's idiots that's
right in almost everything that's right
almost any area of life this culture has
lost its
mind
so deprogrammed from that doing your own
thought your own independent critical
thinking uh my my good friend one of my
best friends is a pastor he says don't
let the world teach you theology
talk about deprogramming right and so
you know where are you getting your
truth from where are you what are you
dialing in on are you believing all
these broke people are they giving you
advice about money because they talked
about how many times somebody thought
they were crazy but look at crazy
looking crazy now baby crazy rich
[Laughter]
love it
this is so fun
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm dave ramsey welcome to the ramsey
show ken coleman number one best-selling
author is my co-host his brand new book
comes out tomorrow
from paycheck to purpose the clear path
to doing work you love the baby steps
are a clear path to becoming a baby
steps millionaire
paycheck to purpose outlines the clear
path to doing work you love exactly step
by step by step what you need to do
if you want the goodies all the pre-sale
items that go with it order it today and
you get an extra hundred dollars worth
of stuff that you won't get tomorrow all
for the same twenty dollars not a bad
deal our question today comes from
blinds.com they have a 100 satisfaction
guarantee that means even if you
mismeasure you pick the wrong color they
will remake your blinds for free you get
free samples free shipping and with the
new promos they run every month you'll
save even more use the promo code ramsey
to get the best deal today's question
comes from john in indianapolis i have a
high stress job that pays 230 000 a year
in addition to dealing with aging
parents teenagers in the pandemic the
job is wearing me out and it's having a
negative impact on my life i've been
offered a new job where i'd take a 30 to
40 thousand dollar your pay cut with the
same company but the work is
invigorating and entrepreneurial i'm
having trouble justifying this pay
decrease although i feel i'm gonna be
happier our only debt is our mortgage
college is funded my wife earns a great
salary and we have a healthy savings
account so why am i struggling with this
decision i don't want to be one of those
unhappy people saddle with a job they
don't like yet they stay for the money
well
john then don't be one of those people
you don't want to be one of those people
so my mentor this guy to the left of me
he's got a great little tactic when he
gives a speech and he's talking about
money changing you go
just aside just a little quick clap and
i think john you don't want to be one of
those unhappy people that stay just for
the money let me help you a little bit
you don't need the money a thirty to
forty thousand dollar pay cut right now
uh for you is going to take you just
below two hundred thousand a year and
your wife makes a great salary we don't
even know that number so you guys may be
in that three hundred thousand range
you're above 250 this work is clearly
having a tremendous impact on you all of
the signs are there you need to give
yourself permission to do the right
thing and this is the right thing i will
also tell you that this new job being
invigorating and entrepreneurial tells
me two things that there's probably a
path
back up to the money you're making now
if not going beyond that i don't have uh
that information in front of me but this
is the right move you don't need to feel
bad about it you're not doing the wrong
thing you know dave it reminds me you
know we heard our last the the debt free
screamer talk about deep programming
and this is an issue here where we are
so
programmed in our world to put
significance
and success completely in the financial
bucket and yet that's just simply not
the case and it makes people like john
feel like if i take a strategic cut
that i can absolutely absorb that
somehow i'm doing the wrong thing or
it's a dumb thing or a not smart thing
and i think that's real but in this case
john this is the right move all the way
around
i don't think it's dumb and i agree with
ken i would take it
however i think you need to keep in mind
that the aging parents and the teenagers
are still going to be there
so where's your stress really coming
from
what's really going on
i mean if you've got some family stuff
that's out of balance and you need to
set some boundaries have you got some
tough decisions you've been unwilling to
make
uh with either one of those other two
subjects
that are putting that are the real cause
of the stress make real sure you're
treating the right problem
not the symptom
and uh the second thing is this again
i'll agree with kent take the job john
however i do not agree
with the supposition that the only way
you find happiness is to move down an
income
that you can't find something that's
invigorating what was the phrase he used
an entrepreneurial that pays 300 000 a
year
why is it we always think to be happy we
have to make less money what is this
stupid thing that's floating around in
this culture that says that
by the way if you do something you love
you're better at it and you should make
more money
ultimately yeah i mean but this idea
that you have to have poverty associated
with happiness or less money associated
with happiness is absurd so i would
choose a third option as a consideration
and that is where can i find something
invigorating entrepreneurial that pays
300.
oh
why is it we have to go down all the
time i don't understand this so anyway
it's okay if you do and i'm going with
ken's recommendation but i'm going to
challenge you on those two points make
sure you got the parents and the
teenager thing working because dude
that's still gonna be there yep and you
got to be careful what you think the
stress is so you know the first time
that happened to me is when i filed
bankruptcy
the bankruptcy attorney um
didn't do a lot of things right but he
said one really wise thing
he said uh because you're you're under
this tremendous weight
of debt which feels like he feels right
you got this overwhelming anxiety over
the top of you and where you're like
something's standing on your chest i
can't breathe and then the day you file
bankruptcy that that's just poof you
know most of it anyway is gone right and
you got some more stress points but by
and large i've been fighting it for two
and a half years i was ready to set down
the rock baby yeah okay but that guy
looks at me and he goes you know what
filing bankruptcy does not create an
income
yeah mic drop yeah that's right it's
really good you know it's like you know
you're not gonna prosper
because you filed bankruptcy you've
still got to go out there to kill it and
drag it home whatever it is you still
gotta find a way to eat
and of course i respond i got this
figured out but but i mean it's still i
can remember that 30 years ago i
remember that conversation right now
and so that's what i always think you
know be careful what you wish for
because it might may not be touching
what you're talking about you're still
the common denominator you're still
going to be in the next marriage you're
still going to be in the next job your
parents and your
teens are still going to be there after
you make this move you're the common
denominator follows you everywhere i'm
glad you brought that up because
he could take this move and it could be
on paper all the things that he says it
is
but if the personal life is burning
the job doesn't solve that right it will
help right in some ways you've got some
purpose as you move into the office but
if it's 70 job stress and 30 family
it'll help it'll help if it's the other
way around it's not going to make a
difference you're just going to make
less money all right exactly right and i
think that was a really great call out
here and i would also agree with you in
this situation if that's the only thing
that you've got but it's rarely the only
thing and this is situation well i've
got an opportunity here
and it's going to be better in all these
ways and it's less money and i think
you're right you got to consider the
whole field the whole universe of jobs
samantha's in charlotte north carolina
hi samantha welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave hi ken it's an honor to speak
with you both
you too how can we help um
well my husband and i have well we're on
baby step seven we have five different
retirement accounts between us both i'm
wanting to open a sep ira
with our business to reduce our taxable
income but my question is is there a
maximum number of retirement accounts a
couple can have without being penalized
somehow
no
there's not a maximum you can do you can
do whatever you need to do
uh if you have too much money sitting in
an old 401k or old ira it could affect
your roth contributions but that's all
and so but those are old but in terms of
can you do it you can do a sep ira
you could do a sep roth ira instead
uh you can do a roth ira at the same
time
and your husband can do his 401k over at
work now the sep is
any employees have been with you more
than three of the last five years
uh are also going to get the same
percentage of their income that you put
in the percentage of your income into it
so do you have employees been with you a
while
we do not okay so you can put in up to
about 13.6 is what the calculation is
going to end up being 13.6 percent of
your
profit on that business your taxable
income on that business can go into that
sep and you can make it a a roth sep is
what i would do and get with one of our
smart vester pros at ramseysolutions.com
and get signed up for that
and uh um you know they can help you
walk through the process but you know
there's a lot of different kinds of
accounts you can have 401ks you could
have uh you could have a 401k at your
work you could have a 403 b at his work
you could have seps you can have ir
individual iras at the same time uh as
you've got all these others that there's
you know there's a couple of them
there's one or two of them that overlap
now now and each of them have an in each
of them have a contribution limit that
you can do
but uh but the number of accounts no i
by and large there's very little if any
limitation on that so good question ken
coleman ramsey personality my co-host
today here on the air this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host thank
you for jumping in the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five ken coleman
ramsey personality is my co-host today
today is the last day to order his new
book from paycheck to purpose the clear
path to doing work you love
for twenty dollars and get a hundred
dollars worth of pre-sale items thrown
in
all kinds of goodies there you can get
the video course guides templates resume
templates you can get the audio book and
the ebook all included the pre-order
ends tonight because the book goes on
sale in bookstores and around america
all day starting tomorrow and all of you
that have pre-ordered the book they will
all ship
this week to you so you're going to be
getting them as soon as possible uh
we've been able to uh work through the
uh
pandemic paper shortage and got the book
got the books out no questions got them
out into uh into tarjay and into barnes
and noble
and into that fine french store and um
uh all those places right and all the
places great books are sold and uh of
course amazon has them and of course
ramsey solutions has them if you want to
do the pre-order and get all the deal go
to rmzsolutions.com
today today's your last day gary's with
us gary is in kansas city hi gary how
are you
hi dave team ramsey uh
honor to speak with you you too
i wanted to uh just go over
what's in my life and my brother's lives
a little bit of a complex
quest question we need answered
regarding uh
my mom who died a couple of months ago
and uh some of the fall out from that
oh thanks what happened why did she pass
away from
i think officially it was covet however
there was more to it she was she had a
lot on her mind she she was dealing with
my dad who had dementia
she was uh
lived a life of service and entertaining
for us and just provided her life she
was very joyful person and a lot of
friends a lot of uh
a lot of great relationships she
established and we uh
we were just blessed for a couple of
show weeks ago you mentioned uh what we
inherit from our parents you know a big
cash nest egg and all maybe that's not
so good but instead is better a
a work ethic and i think we got that
from my parents god god bless them you
know uh man anyway
we miss him please her fiercely and uh
so
it's it's sad part of it's
so that's joy but there's a sad part
that we're trying to work through
she was scammed the last two years of
the life pretty pretty and she bought
into spot into it pretty pretty deeply
um and we were sort of tracking it but
not real uh
not as close as we should have as as i'm
remote from her i have
some some mega million scam or something
got it got into her head and uh
she was very uh concerned about you know
providing some kind of uh inheritance
for her for us
is your dad still is your dad still
alive
he is and and yes he's with us and
my middle brother is really stepped up
and he's he's doing dad basically taking
the place of what my mom was doing so
did she lose all of their assets
in a word yes okay she sold a house
about a year and a half ago
all the proceeds spent and
there's nothing left but debt
the debt is the debt is not that so the
debt is like kind of small but it's so
the qui where we're going with this
question is the ethics of it so
she had in this scam the the scammers
had convinced her to buy three iphone
12s
and and and they would reimburse her in
all this and it was somehow how she was
going to pay the taxes as well that's
where a lot of the money apparently went
and he had a she uh so she bought these
three iphone 12s they're a thousand
bucks a piece and uh
a big the cell company or a big
uh
one of the big ones um
now has this bill out she wasn't getting
the uh
installments of
funding that were said to be coming from
the scammers of course so at the point
where she was seeing she bought these
phones and of course shipped them off
all at her expense
with a cell phone
provider companies or whatever
they uh
they they got free two free phones she
kept one of them and now she wasn't
going to pay the
finance and find it you know your
finances these things and then she was i
guess gonna so she didn't pay the three
thousand dollars off we still have this
three thousand dollar bill
and
there's nothing to be redeemed as far as
her credit because her credit shot she
had a great credit she did great things
with her money for her life when you
pass away gary
what you own
stands good for what you owe
and so she has a 3 000 debt
does she own
your dad and her own
anything
he's got
a car
um
there's there's little penny any stuff
that that is around a car
uh
the uh i mean there was some
some little some hard assets that were
were uh able to uh
liquidate in an event and that wasn't
even to be done but we weren't really uh
they come after her estate i guess
that's all they can do they can come
after her estate and if you guys sold an
antique dresser for ten thousand dollars
and kept that money instead of paying
this bill then they would have recourse
against you guys
okay so yeah
she uh saddled us with this it sounds
like yeah what you own
stands good for what you owe when you
pass away but your kids do not inherit
debt but your kids will not get an
inheritance until the debt is paid out
of
the things that they owned your mom and
dad owned
where is your dad living he's in a uh a
memory care facility okay
all right so he's got a checking account
with three thousand dollars in it
yes there's that yeah we've got a little
bit of yeah my brothers and i are all if
this is the only debt that there is
you're gonna have to pay that debt in
order to clear the rest of the assets
even though they're penny annie
it's not ethics it's the law
yeah okay
and they that you know they're probably
for three thousand dollars not gonna
chase you guys down and you know put you
in a headlock and and you know try to
get the three thousand bucks out of you
as a practical matter but that's
technically the way this works and so
morally the way this works
understood yeah you're gonna you're
gonna have the unhappy experience of
completing the scam
right goodness um
okay and how prevalent is this is this a
very proud
do i need to get as i retire from my
military should i go into
uh detective work in cyber and
regarding trying to protect elders from
their yeah
the only problem is the people that will
be paying you are broke because they've
been scammed
but yeah it's pretty prevalent that's a
pretty standard the iphone scam you know
that whole thing that's fairly normal we
hear it sadly more often than we should
and um
yeah it's
it's it's pretty prevalent
but i don't know whether you can make an
income doing it or not that's a whole
other discussion
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk they use
the same network as the larger providers
for much less for just 30 a month get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
with no contract the average family
saves over 70 dollars a month by
switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personalities my
co-host today open phones a triple eight
eight two five
five
two two five
so if you suspect
that a loved one is being scammed
suggested steps
i think you have to have a sit down with
them and say hey i think something's
fishy here can we dig into this and try
not to put them on the defensive but ask
some questions dig in uh do a little bit
of
your own version of a private
investigator and uh dive into it and
then show them hey this doesn't seem to
make a lot of sense and many times they
just need somebody else to kind of look
at and go hey this doesn't seem right
and i think that's the first thing i do
and if it's not right i'd say hey this
is a bad idea we're going to get you out
of this let me help you know because i
think there's a certain amount of
embarrassment there oh always think
about that you know so go in i go in a
little easy i'm trying to put myself in
the shoes of talking to my father you
know if he were to have that situation
and i'm gonna have to come in there
and uh not embarrass him not make him
feel like he was totally duped make the
bad guy the bad guy not them the bad guy
that would be my approach that's exactly
right that's exactly how you do it and
it's really not hard to research these
scams that's correct well a simple
google search i'll pop up in front of
you and
you know
mega millions scam spanish letter scam
nigerian letter scam there's several
versions out there
and uh um
the people get sucked into all kinds of
different things and just if you just if
you have enough information you know
where there's cell phone and mega
millions both mentioned all you do is
type that in and boom it'll pop up show
you exactly what they're doing how
they're working it yeah what what's
going on and then you just can send that
link and go listen this is what's
happening to you yeah yeah let's get you
out of this and so um you know you
didn't do anything wrong no uh you were
just trying to leave an inheritance what
a horrible
motivation
but uh the number of times i've seen
people
in the name of leaving an inheritance to
their children
get into stuff they should not get into
is over 30 years of doing this it's all
the time oh i'm sure bad financial
products
scam real straight up scams like that
lady got scammed
but all in the name of i want to leave
the kids something which is a misguided
thing to start with the most important
thing you can leave them is to not do
that kind of stuff
yeah i just i've learned this you know
if it's too good to be true it's almost
always
if it smells fishy there's fish involved
i mean come on
you know if you think if you i got a bad
feeling you know why you got this this
just felt weird you know why it felt
weird because it was weird oh yeah
that's why it felt weird yeah and trust
yourself you know yeah i'm glad you said
that so you know i'm a big nerd and i
read a lot i was reading a book i'm
reading a book right now by a physicist
and you know you talk about you it's
legendary you talk about sharon dave's
wife sharon she's she's got incredible
great great great common sense you
always talk about that feeling you say
it the way that i can't say it but you
can say it
there it is
and but you know there's actually the
physicists have done research on this
real quick they had they put heart
monitors on world-class grand master
chess players
to find out if that gut feeling is that
a gut feeling or is it actually tied to
the same
mechanism that we kind of say well i
logically thought through this decision
long story short this grand master chess
player's heart rate spiked every time in
the match before they made an incorrect
move and the the so the the conclusion
was that gut feeling
that's actually your brain sending a
physical response to your body and your
heart is warning you
don't do it don't do it and so i just
wanted to point out that when you have a
bad feeling
don't put that off as a gut thing as
some mysterious thing that's your brain
and your body combining to go stop yeah
but i had a weird feeling about him
you know that's because he's weird right
you know
that's just you know that's the thing
it's just trust yourself yeah and um you
know because you know that about 20
times while that lady was sending off
that money of those cell phones and
selling her house to do this that she
had those things you know she had an
inkling
that this was wrong and so the way you
can step in is to tap into that and say
you gotta trust yourself
because yourself is telling yourself
this is not this bad deal this is a bad
thing trust yourself and i used to say
trust your gut instinct and my friend
who's a pastor said that's not your gut
that's the holy spirit don't call the
holy spirit your gut
trust god's spirit that's in you which
will speak to you and say don't do it
yeah yeah that's it
yeah and your body is sounding more like
a demon than it did it kind of did but
hey that's kind of what we have to get
rid of sometimes right
alex is with us in minneapolis hi alex
how are you
hi i'm doing good how are you today
better than i deserve how can we help
hey so my husband and i are both about
30 respectively we make about 200k
together
we have a little baby just one kid we
have no debt
we are investing in full we tithe in
full
etc um
we also have our six month emergency
fund saved up and we have a little bit
of extra money
and save we've got about 40 grand on top
of our six-month emergency fund that
we're not really sure what to do with
um
we're thinking about putting it into our
house to pay against the principal yeah
the only time to be in the house for
another three years or so it doesn't
matter playing off
pay it off anyway
pay it off anyways as fast as you can
okay we can do that yeah you should be
putting no more than you should be
putting no more than 15 of your income
currently into retirement
and you should be saving for your kids
college and every dollar that you have
beyond that after having a reasonable
life because you're at a good stage of
this goes towards the house that's what
we call baby steps four five and six
now when the house is paid off then i
would go back and i would max out
retirement but until then i want this
house paid off because we've discovered
in our study of millionaires the largest
study of millionaires ever done in north
america that the typical millionaire the
first million to two million dollars
worth of net worth that they gain is
from a paid for house and a funded
retirement
okay not one or the other it's both
that makes sense we thought that wasn't
the answer we're just nervous about it
it's okay it's okay here's the thing
you're not going to lose the money by
paying the house mortgage down because
if you do sell the house within three
years which you're anticipating they're
going to write you a check at closing
all that money comes back out
yeah so do you i mean i it sounds like
you recommend that over we're planning
to move and we know where we want to go
next by buying a piece of property so
you recommend
paying the house instead of putting
money on the property right away yep
yeah okay
because the two things i run into are
not a paid four third piece of property
in the millionaire study i run into paid
for houses and fully funded retirement
plans that's what we run into all the
time that's where the data leads me and
so i think i'm going that direction
every time there every time so good
question dave what's the emotion there
because she's they're they're amazing
what an unbelievable
job so they're such a good job yes
what's the emotion there where's that
come from on that what's behind that
this is a person who's very smart with
their money should i put that 40 000
into the house when i'm moving in three
years what what's what's causing that to
think oh we don't know if that's smart
is what she feels it feels like it's
trapped i feel like the money's trapped
okay can't do anything with it it's in
now in the house okay and that is that
makes sense by the way that's also a
good thing right because you don't
accidentally buy a bass boat with it you
know um
oops
there's that boat in the is true yeah
and so when you trap it in there but it
does feel like oh i can't get it back
out i can't get to it that's good um and
and that's why you know someone who's
that smart i still remind them even
though i know they know this that
they're gonna get their money back out
of the house when they sell it because
you need to emotionally feel that oh
it's not really gone i'm just storing it
there
that's good storing it as opposed to
being stuck it's not stuck it's stored
oh yeah and it's it's got a lock on it
that's key on it but it's stored open
phones here at triple eight eight two
five five two two five today is the last
day to order ken's brand new book from
paycheck to purpose the clear path to
doing work you love
and you can order it today and get for
twenty dollars and get a hundred dollars
worth of extras including resume
templates video courses guides
resume guides and the audio and the
ebook all included if you order today if
you order tomorrow for 20 you will get
the book
today you got all the other stuff yeah
move on it tomorrow's launch day so get
on it while you can
ride at ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at zip
recruiter have made the whole job search
way easier ziprecruiter is rated the
number one job site in the us by g2 and
it's free so how does it work
first go to ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's
ziprecruiter.com slash ken sign up today
absolutely free and let zip recruiter
work for you
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today on the debt-free stage in
the lobby of ramsey solutions tyler and
melissa are with us hey guys how are you
doing good hey dave welcome where do you
guys live
so we live in a small town called
trenton it's near cincinnati ohio it's
about 12 000 people in it okay cool well
welcome to nashville good to have you
and all the way here to do a debt-free
scream how much did you pay off so we
paid off 49
992 dollars love it how long did that
take it took two and a half years okay
and your range of income during that
time about 60 to 70 000 although at one
point it was about 40 when i had a back
injury and was out of work
what do y'all do for a living so i'm a
sewer pipe inspector
at a company called televac
environmental
and i'm a wedding photographer and a
stay-at-home mom oh fun good for you
guys so what kind of debt was this fifty
thousand dollars
mainly my stolen my student loans
and then car
um
medical bills credit card debt just the
whole nine yards pretty much so how long
y'all been married a little over four
years okay so two and a half years ago
something happened and you start this
ramsey journey stuff what'd you do what
happened so what happened was our church
the little church in hamilton ohio they
ended up hosting a financial peace
university class
and that changed it all so i i just want
to give praise to the the people the
leaders for that mike and liz knutson
like
really changed their lives wow
very cool so you you go in there and
they're they're announcing it on sunday
morning that there's going to be a class
and you decide to take it yes yep
we knew there was we knew the way we
were handling our money
wasn't the greatest and we just knew it
could benefit our family
and we had a lot of weight from like
medical bills when we our daughter was
born just a little bit before that so
kind of that pressure i kind of like
pushed us into it yeah okay cool yeah
there's something about having that
first kid and then there's some bills
laying around you're like i gotta get
this mess clean now
kind of kind of a wake-up call huh yeah
way to go proud of you guys great job
very very cool okay so what did you do
to get out of debt tell people what the
key to getting out of debt is
so there i mean there's a lot of keys
for us um a couple of them was like
vision you know we had to have a road
map
kind of figure out where you know what's
coming in what's going out
um communal care right we had support
from
community family friends co-workers that
would kind of talk to me along the
journey
uh our my parents let us live live in
their basement for a little bit her
uncle ended up gifting us a car wow you
know so
and my parents ended up gifting us a car
as well wow
but a really big one especially for
marriages i would say is forgiveness
like because you can you could use the
the budget as a weapon
if you wanted to
and we do you know anybody that might do
that
i've definitely done it a few times so
yeah
so uh so melissa you had to go uh-uh no
weapon we're working together
um it definitely took a little bit to
actually get on train and stuff but
because i love hobby lobby taser max
target you know there's that
okay so a weapon to control melissa's
spending
okay i got it all right okay that works
too it works for me i'll go with it hey
the good news is you got on the same
page and started working it together and
uh
so what was the
hardest part of this whole process for
y'all
the hardest part of the process i guess
was like the consistent grind but the
the truly hardest was like when i was
out of work so we're
i ended up getting a back injury about
almost a year into it and i was out of
work for about eight months whoa yes
bad back injury um
my discs were herniated and that some my
mild grades spinal stenosis and that wow
and during that time she kind of really
helped us out with
you know more wedding taking on more
weddings as a photographer and that but
i went through kind of a depression and
that and
ended up
you know adding some more debt
you know through that process and that
and
but god so preserved our lives and you
know
eight months after that we kept kept
going on this whole track and then ended
up two and a half years boom we paid it
all off wow so i wanted to ask you guys
about going into that class financial
peace university i'm just curious
you know it's it's like we all revert to
being childlike in our lives even as
adults you know you remember that first
day of kindergarten you know the first
day of junior high it's scary you're
walking in i'm curious what was it like
even though it was your church is that
right what was it like to walk into that
class environment this is a brand new
thing uh for you melissa obviously
you're kind of like i don't know
i'm curious what was the dynamic like as
you went in week in week out
like definitely it was like nervous at
first like i didn't know what to expect
um but definitely i think just like the
workbook and going through that with our
class and like just the slides i just
remember like us having conversations
i think like weekly just talking about
it and like
how it could help our family and all
that stuff so i just
it was definitely
mind-boggling definitely took a lot to
take in but it definitely was worth it
what was the part about other people in
the class that maybe brought you into
some comfort level or hey we're not the
only ones talk about that i mean there's
definitely other families in there um
people who like even were childless but
it was just nice seeing other people
that were like us going through the same
things people who had credit cards that
needed
to be done with that and all that stuff
so it was just really nice to know that
we weren't we weren't alone yeah it
makes you feel not so weird that you're
not the only person on the planet that
messed up with exactly
yeah it kind of normalizes that normal's
broke yeah i just don't be normal
anymore yeah yeah well way to go guys it
sounds like you had quite a long journey
there the grind and the
setback and then coming back after the
setback and well done very well done
very proud of you guys dave i want to
ask melissa real quick so wedding
photographer and i'm looking at the two
and a half year timeline here your
wedding's during covid yeah how did you
keep that going um
kind of stressful but a lot of my
couples i'm very thankful for them um
they didn't actually reschedule for the
following year they kept their day
either had a smaller wedding or just
postponed to like another date and i was
available so it was just nice being able
to keep my couples and
yeah it was definitely challenging
especially it's just yeah covered good
for you that's awesome wow very tough
and you brought your daughter with you
what is her name and age her name is
leilani um she is three and a half years
old all right
and this is our why this is why we did
all this just to change that so hi
leilani
girl i love it unicorn squad yeah it's a
good squad to be on i've heard i heard
it i was unaware that it was a squad i
got to do some research dave
you need to catch up on these things you
know
papa dave knows these things that's
right we got we got uniforms coming out
our ears all right way to go guys very
proud of you we got a copy of the legacy
journey for you that's the next chapter
in your story to be baby steps
millionaires you're on your way way to
go and a copy of the total money
makeover for you to give away and get
someone else started on their journey
maybe one of those young couples you're
shooting their way you never know you
never know very good stuff all right
tyler melissa and leilani from the
cincinnati area trenton fifty thousand
dollars paid off in two and a half years
making 60 to 70 count it down let's hear
a debt free screen ready ronnie ready
lonnie three two one we're
[Music]
[Applause]
i
love it
man that's so fun
it never gets old it never gets old
financial peace university class taught
ramsey plus taught in a in a local
church uh somebody jumps in at just the
time that they need it perfect timing
and uh and boom here we set things are
going the way they are supposed to go
very very well done that's a great
testimony too folks if you're
considering going i don't know anybody
there i don't even go to church there
trust me they're going to welcome you
the people that are coordinators are
some of the finest people i've ever had
the privilege to meet in my life and
then you just heard they're going to be
other people and they have the same
stuff you have there's no shame it's
everywhere just because those people
aren't good with money join a community
most people aren't and she said the
communal party that's right family
helped them
they were in a group that's a big part
of the process it really is
very very well done you guys proud of
you
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsay personality is my
co-host today here on the ramsey show
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five kansas city's on the line
michael is with us hey michael how are
you
hey dave great to talk to you
sure you too how can we help
i'm calling uh
my mother passed away september of 20.
we are at the end she didn't have a will
we're at the end of the probate process
and we're trying to figure out what we
should do with the house
she owes about ninety thousand dollars
[Music]
there's some foundation damage i'm not
sure if we sold it as is
it would even be worth
what she owes
[Music]
my brother uh me and my brother were the
uh
the heirs
i tried to get him to
see if he could get a loan to
take over the loan because he wants to
stay there
but he's a convicted felon that's never
really
thought of working other than buying and
selling used cars so he only makes about
twelve thousand dollars a year
how's he gonna pay a thousand dollar a
month payment
well he got uh quite a bit of money from
life insurance and things like that
but if he doesn't work you know that's
gonna run out obviously exactly
so he you know i was like well maybe you
know we can both go in on it but i don't
really want to be involved
especially with him
right yeah um so here's the thing
if the house is worth
90 000 and there's 90 000 odd on it it's
not worth anything to you you could just
let him take it
was um
as the mortgage goes do we need to
you're not on the mortgage are you you
didn't sign the mortgage did you
no here's my mom's mortgage you have any
idea what kind of mortgage it is fannie
mae f-h-a-v-a
it's a
just a fha okay then your brother can
take over the payments without uh having
refinanced it
oh he can yeah okay yeah that fha will
not foreclose on an estate
they'll let him just pay the payments as
long as he keeps him current obviously
if he didn't win he quits keeping them
current they'll take the house but yeah
he's been paying the payment since he
passed okay he's living there taking
care of her okay
um i just let him have it then
let him just pay the payment don't miss
a payment though
no well i thought maybe if we put a
little money into it we could probably
sell it for
twice what what she's owed on it and
then make a little money on it
okay that's a different scenario than
what you laid out
you said the house was worth what was
owed on
it yeah if we didn't do any repairs yeah
yeah and uh how much insurance money did
you and your brother get
uh we ended up getting about 80 000 a
piece
okay and how much in repairs would you
do and then what would the house be
worth if you did those repairs i think
if we put 20 into it we could probably
sell it for 160 to 180
in this market
what do you make a year
i'm like 80
and i'm you know married with kids and
okay
and i got my own mortgage and a second
mortgage to help my kids go to college
but uh
but you got 80 000 in the bank
yeah
so d because here's the thing your
brother would like to stay there if you
guys both put in 10 each
of your insurance money
you know you're going to get that 10
back and another 30 or another 20 or
something right
each right after all the smoke clears
and go through all this trouble and
everything
well he would actually get a little more
because he's been paying the mortgage
yeah
okay
um i'm going to give you some
weird advice
okay
you're signing up for a bunch of hassle
your brothers had a mess of a life and
needs a leg up
i'm gonna take my 80 000 and let him
have the house and walk away
that's a gift to your brother a little
bit but it's also a gift to yourself and
lack of hassle lack of problems lack of
whatever he was there he took care of
your mom
yes he's paid the payments yes all that
but uh this will give him a good hard
fresh start if he wants to put 20 of his
80 into it and flip it he can make a
little money i don't think he's going to
do that
um
and i think you can just walk away from
the hassle and the problems that you're
getting ready to sign up for and do your
do your brother
a favor do something nice for him in the
process i think this is a win-win to
walk away
what do you think
i agree that's a great idea how much
debt do you have
i have
20 000 on a second mortgage to help my
kids go to college
yeah so i paid i have a
mortgage yeah so
i agree with you a second bank some of
it for the rest of college that's right
and you got to clean clear life out of
this you guys have gone through the
grieving of losing your mom together
um and i i i want
it to be a clear conversation with him
that i'm giving him a gift that might be
worth as much as twenty thousand bucks
and and that uh that thought process has
come up in our discussions but uh so i
would just really want to get some
advice so i appreciate it yeah i think
this is a good time for generosity on
your part yeah
that's going to benefit everyone it's
just a thought yeah i couldn't agree
more dave i think this is a nice move it
takes the kind of takes it off of his
takes it off of his shoulders it's done
i've gifted my brother i've given him an
opportunity and thus doing so i'm not
going to get any more money but i got 80
from mom i'm debt free except for the
house it with a stroke of one check uh
and still somebody got some money left
money left the kids go to the kids to go
to college yeah and we're not tied up in
some kind of real estate flip this house
crap on cable tv because you know more
about this than i do but it's never as
simple as well it's just 20. it's just
20 and then we'll flip it and it's it's
all it always takes longer and you're
trying to find construction people in a
weird market right now and
i i i just um
you know if there's 150 000 bucks on the
line we might talk about it but there's
not yeah uh and when all the smoke
clears on this it might not have been
worth the trouble anyway that kind of
thing
so good question
all right daniel's with us in new york
city hi daniel welcome to the ramsey
show hey guys what's going on
hey how can we help sure
hi okay so my question is my question is
basically and don't get mad at me dave
but
i think i want to lease a car mm-hmm
and i know you're not supposed to lease
a car
supposed to buy a used one in cash
but
i think i can afford to lease a car and
i think it's the better move for me
like i'm curious what you have to say on
that
well you kind of know what i'm gonna say
obviously don't you
yeah but maybe um well daniel i think
this is where you lay out your case for
dave you know what he's gonna say so why
do you think it's a better deal than
buying a used car okay good idea
right so why i think is because
i could let's say by uh try to find a
reliable used car for like a 10 or 15
000
but i personally wouldn't feel
comfortable driving that around in terms
of reliability because for work i'm
driving sometimes two hours in the
middle of nowhere
i just don't want to you know risk
anything i want to have
a new car and 10 years from now i don't
want to be driving a 10 year old car
okay so that's that's why for me
that's why i think and uh i don't have
in your ear how old
i'm 23. and your house your income is
what
i make uh 120 okay good for you how many
miles are you putting on that car
i would probably keep within the 10 000
miles
a year not if you're driving
a day that's where i had a problem with
your math are you driving four miles an
hour no but it's not it's not every day
i work for myself so i'm more
i'm not working every day
dude you're in prison with those lease
miles but
so wait a minute you can't have it both
ways okay you can't have it i drive two
and a half miles a day i drive two and a
half hours every day so i need a
reliable car but wait a minute no i
don't drive two and a half hours a day i
only drive ten thousand miles a year so
i don't need a reliable car
occasionally i drive two and a half
hours
yeah frequently okay well not frequently
over 10 000 miles
the occasional frequency
it doesn't add up you can't daniel you
can't have it both ways the math doesn't
work in your discussion okay
so here's the thing here's the thing
here's the thing
broke people
drive new cars
there's two people that drive brand new
cars
mega millionaires
and broke people these are the only two
people the vast majority of new cars are
broke people because they go down in
value
like a rock
you're either going to put the miles on
this fleece car you're going to blow the
lease up or you're not going to put the
miles on it and it's going to eat you
alive
you can do what you want to do you call
me there's no possible way i'm going to
tell a 23 year old who's smart enough to
make 120 000 to go fleece a stupid car
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status simple choice
i'm dave ramsey your host ken coleman
ramsey personality host of the king
coleman show is my co-host today
tomorrow is book launch day for ken his
brand new book from paycheck to purpose
the clear path to
to doing work you love uh is in
bookstores available tomorrow be shipped
tomorrow to those of you that have
pre-purchased it speaking of which if
you pre-order by midnight tonight you
will spend twenty dollars for the book
and get a hundred dollars plus
worth of goodies uh added in included in
the process
and uh man pretty incredible you're
gonna get resume templates guides a
video course the audio book the e-book
all of it included
all for just purchasing the 20 book why
because pre-orders matter towards the
best seller list and we bribe you into
pre-ordering because you're going to get
the book anyway you might as well get
all the goodies so go ahead and order it
right now at ramseysolutions.com while
you have the chance
last day to do that tomorrow is launch
day
lots of media and stuff happening this
week for you you're gonna be really busy
yeah we're excited we're getting the
word out and uh it's uh it's it we would
have never known that the scenario that
we sit in now this great resignation
people considering moving coming out of
the pandemic moving more than they've
ever moved before in their work because
they know that there's more there they
want a bigger paycheck but they also
want to do work that has
more values attached to it so it's very
exciting time to see what's going to
happen as the world shifts certainly
the american workforce is shifting
tremendously and so we're excited about
it going to be talking about it anywhere
we can possibly talk about it yeah so if
you're one of those 55 or so thinking
about changing jobs listen you don't
want to just change jobs
you don't want to go from the frying pan
and the fire
more money and i hate my job in a toxic
environment yeah
uh you need to be careful what you wish
for right
and so from paycheck to
purpose
making as much or more money than you
make now and get meaning
yeah this is the goal
you don't have to take a 50 pay cut to
be a happy camper no matter of fact
that's not going to make you a happy
camper
money doesn't make you happy that's not
the point but the point is you need to
get after this so hey paycheck to
purpose at ramseysolutions.com
get it while you can today with all the
goodies attached daniel's going to start
off this hour in knoxville hi daniel how
are you
hi dave hi ken thanks for taking my call
i'm doing well
great how can we help um so i have a
baby step four question for y'all
um so in order to maintain that 25 ratio
across fund categories in my ira
uh i feel like i'm only ever thinking
money into the international fund the
basis and that fund is is much higher
than the others and it's growing right
so every time i deposit money it's
always into that international fund
because it's formed not as well as the
rest is that still the correct way to
invest or am i interpreting y'all's
advice incorrectly
way to go you're really paying attention
the international category of the four
categories sucks
i mean it's bad
it's ugly
and so you notice that that's a good
thing
and what you're trying to do is
rebalance your portfolio with your
monthly contributions
that's right i would i would not do that
i'm fine if a category's sucking if it
gets a little bit out of balance
because i'm going to end up with less in
a sucky category
okay until it comes roaring back and
then when it comes roaring back i got so
pissed off about this international
category underperforming because i've
given the same information the same and
i personally invest that way my personal
401k is like we're talking about just 25
into each category period and i have i
don't go back and rebalance some people
go back and rebalance every year or two
and if you want to that's fine it's not
the end of the world but you're not
going to usually see a huge change on
uh your results if you do now what i did
do daniel just as a side note uh because
you noticed something that a lot of
people haven't really brought up
is that that i i considered maybe we
need to change our advice
because that category's so bad maybe we
just need to go third third third and
drop the international because for it's
like a 20-year run of suck i mean it's
it's bad
and so what i did though i went back
with my elp or my smartmester pro and i
had him run a whole bunch of scenarios
and i told him what i was thinking about
i said not only am i thinking about
changing mind i'm thinking about
changing because i'm not going to change
mine and not tell y'all okay i think the
market's moved i think this
international category is bad i was
ready to go there and we ran the
scenarios out 14 different ways and they
found all kinds of anomalies and all
kinds of things in the marketplace
because i always look back 30 40 years i
don't look back just three years
or even 15 years right i want to look
back i want to see how this market moves
how it reacts
and
they said okay over 40 years here's what
it would look like if you had the
international in your mix at 25 going in
no rebalancing
back to your original question and
here's what it would look like if you
didn't have the international
and even though the international sucked
it has offset the other times that the
domestic market is turned down it's shot
up because it runs inverse of the other
markets usually uh enough times that i
actually end up with more money with the
sucky category in there
which is weird
so i left it i left it in my portfolio
and i did not change my recommendations
after running out actual hypotheticals
they're called in that world and running
it out that way but yeah you i would not
recommend to do what you're doing
uh it's not the other world if you do
but i think you're working too hard to
get a lame horse to run
and so uh throwing that extra money on
that international so i just put 25 on
everything and if you want to rebalance
or move some around a little bit every
if it gets way out of whack that'd be
fine
but uh i think over a long period of
time the thing will probably pretty
naturally rebalance or get close to it a
long period being 20 30 years not two
years
so that that's the thing i have never
done what you're doing i've always done
25 each period a fourth each i've not
done it not rebalanced with the
contribution rate in order to get it to
catch up uh
if you do that you're probably going to
be okay but i think you'll make more
money the way i'm talking about than the
way you're doing it just tonight i think
mathematically that's the way it's going
to work if
when you say to him okay if you do that
so it's fine i don't think you're going
to win and you explain why but if
someone was going to do that
what would that allocation look like
instead of 25 well what he's doing is
he's putting
more than 25 percent into the
international because it's dipping to
try to gas try to catch it try to have
it catch up get the balance to catch up
because he's trying to get his balances
to be 25 each so it just depends on how
long you've been doing it and how far in
the hole that account is i mean you
could put 90 percent into the
international and first catch up if you
had to you know got it but i i again i'm
not going that route um
i'm just going to keep plugging along
here here's the interesting thing the
fact that you're looking at this and
you're paying attention and you're using
good critical thinking skills and you're
constantly investing and you're
constantly investing and you're
constantly investing that's what we
found in all the data that causes people
to win more than the technicalities the
technicalities don't end up mattering as
much as paying attention and continuing
paying attention and continuing that's
what we found with all the data on the
millionaires
[Music]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
open phones this hour as we talk about
your life and your money this is the
ramsey show ken coleman ramsey
personality is my co-host today aaron is
with us in
charlotte north carolina hi erin welcome
to the ramsay show
hi david ken how are y'all today great
how can we help
yeah so my question is i i
could apply for a position within my
company that i'm working at now but i'm
not sure if that's the best idea for me
and i'm hoping that y'all could as
unbiased
could help me determine that to give you
a little bit of background i've been in
this company for almost five years
and i was promised growth opportunities
whenever i was hired
unfortunately that seemed to be
has seemed to be a lie the growth track
that i thought i was on uh doesn't
appear to be
a viable track for a growing so i was
wondering what i can and you might say
about that okay
so in your honest opinion have you been
able to
do everything that you feel like you
could do to be the best that you can be
in the contribution you've made over
that five years and you still feel like
no track for growth no opportunities
have come your way
uh yes and no there's definitely the
potential where i could apply for this
new position and it would be the growth
opportunity that i would want however
i'm being told that uh that the work
that i've been doing over the last
several years do not qualify me for this
position as i was originally led to
believe well
whether you were led to believe that or
not the reality is they're telling you
that the work you're doing now hasn't
qualified you for this other position so
it doesn't seem like that's an absolute
possibility so i think going after
something like that where they've told
you your leadership has told you you're
not qualified it's like me trying to go
outside and dunk a basketball tonight on
a 10-foot rim it's just not going to
happen
and so i it feels like to me we've got
to start
short by the way
and can't jump i've got the double
hurdle there
so i i understand the want to
but the there's the leadership has said
you're not qualified for it and i think
you're setting yourself up for
frustration and disappointment that's
unnecessary when i think it might be
time for you to look elsewhere and i
think really it's about getting clear
aaron let me ask you this okay so if i
understand you right you're
coming in
you came into this job and you were told
if you do x y and z
that you'll be able to uh move on to
this type of a position now you've done
x y and z and now they're coming back
and saying that's no not true
what we told you was wrong
uh or what you understood was wrong that
you didn't do x y and z so
uh or even if you do x y and z you're
not qualified is that what you're
telling me
because you've seen the way you for the
way you've structured your sentences two
times you've two different times in this
conversation it sounded like you think
you work for liars
well i we i will say i definitely have a
new manager and i think that this new
manager wants me to apply for this new
position however i i feel like i have if
there's no chance of getting it why does
your new manager want you to apply for
it
that's my thing is i don't understand
the thought process behind my managers
and i've tried to get some clarification
and i'm still uncertain uh co-workers
are saying you should just apply just
apply because there's no harm in it and
i understand that but at the same time
it's causing me more frustration and
emotional and mental harm than it is
doing me good trying to fight for
something that i can't get right well
then they'll do it and you also have
some concerns so confused i don't know
why you can't get it your manager told
you to apply for it he's not going to
tell you to apply for something you
can't get
i honestly i can't tell you why dave
it's been a it's i've been asking for
cross-training opportunities to get a
position like this for at least three
out of the four to five years that i've
been here so why would your manager tell
you to apply for something that you have
zero chance of getting
that's not logical they haven't told me
specifically to apply for it but i i
just get the sense that they would like
for me too okay but didn't you also do
you have a sense that they think you're
not qualified or did they tell you
you're not qualified
they specifically told there's two
positions available one is a
a lower level position than the actual
position that i'm looking for
and that position both are currently
available one i think she would like for
me to apply for the lower position but
she has told me that i'm not eligible
that i'm not qualified for the higher
position all right but do you even want
the higher position let's just remove
all this for a second all this confusion
back and forth do you even want the
position if you were qualified would you
be jumping for it yeah actually whenever
i begin to apply for the position that i
currently have i originally applied for
that position and they asked for me to
apply that for the position that i
currently have okay so i've been asking
for that position ever since i've been
there oh i get i think there's a pattern
here do you feel that you're qualified
on paper for this role
i think so well no
i don't want to think so i mean like do
you know if you look at this position
out in the marketplace like if you went
somewhere else you could make a case
when you're being interviewed that you
should be able to get this job done
so you feel you're qualified i believe
so okay i think it's time to start
looking
today
let's start looking let's test the
market
let's find out there's a there's a gap
here
between you feel like well dave's right
i feel like you feel like they're
dishonest we're like we're not saying
you're wrong we're just saying it's all
over you you feel like they've been
dishonest with you they're not giving
you an opportunity we've got previous
management saying you're not qualified
new person comes in i think she wants
there's too much this stuff going on you
getting your dream job with dishonest
people is not your dream job yeah
that's my thought process as well dude
yeah so you move on yeah if that's if
that's that's why i was asking where
your head was on that issue because you
know if you feel like that because
they're going to cut your knees out from
under you if they're going to cut you
you know right if that's who they are uh
if that's if that's the real conclusion
that you've come to now you beat around
the bush in this conversation
you've not been clear with us we've had
to pull this out of you so keep in mind
i mean i don't know whether you're
trying to be nice or what you're trying
to do but you know bottom line is the
issue here is you don't trust your
leadership and that means it's time to
move yeah listen folks when you feel
there's a lid on you whether you know
all the reasons or not start looking
elsewhere because it's only a matter of
time before you become bitter and then
this thing can turn toxic on your end
and you end up burning a bridge and
hurting your future because you're just
sitting around kind of erring you know
you got to move on and i think i'd start
looking today again
this is such a great time to look and
this is where we find out by the way
if we are qualified yeah if you go out
there and can't get the job then maybe
they were right
that's right they weren't dishonest they
were just being honest they were telling
you the truth you're not qualified we
got to find the common denominator in
this situation yeah
that'll do it or is it leadership go do
some interviews if you don't get the job
then you'll know that's what's going on
so at least hypothetically you'll know
yeah so um yeah the other thing you can
do is have some very clear
precise language not like you used with
us
uh discussions with some leaders in the
organization go listen i really feel
like this is what i was promised i feel
like i've lived up to it so i'm really
struggling with why i
shouldn't get this position can you show
me what i need to do
to be able to follow through on what i
thought we were doing
and that's a very clear
concise
set of words yeah and you don't have to
accuse somebody of lying with to do that
you can just challenge out the situation
say i need to know
why it is that after five years and
having done these things that that i'm
not able to do the thing that i thought
that i signed up for
to get to see this is very important
folks make sure you hear what dave said
most weak leaders they're just weak i
mean that doesn't mean they're bad
people but weak leaders
don't communicate clearly they're afraid
of confrontation so by being honest like
dave just described that kind of
entirely clear very clear put the ball
in their court and if you give them a
clear question and they don't give you
clear back there's your answer this is
weak leadership they're never going to
tell me what i need to hear because we
need to hear it but it takes us being
honest what kind of value do i need to
add to be qualified yes and when i do
that then what you're saying is then i
get the role right and if if they look
at you and go one of the things you have
to learn is clear communication
yeah it might be it could be that could
be the comeback you know so um
it's a possibility
so that's the kind of stuff but there's
nothing wrong with testing the waters
and going and interviewing
especially if you've lost faith in the
integrity of the organization that's
really when it's time to move on
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage
mike and christy are with us hey guys
how are you great dave how about you
good to have you where do you guys live
matt menville tennessee oh just over the
hill just over the hill well thanks for
joining us here guys great and how much
debt have you all paid off 56 984
dollars in the past 18 months wow that
was quick
and your range of income during that
time a hundred thousand between the two
cool what do you all do for a living i'm
a tool maker and a plastic injection
company she's a kindergarten teacher
kindergarten teacher at eastside
elementary all right fun
very fun so what kind of debt was your
57 000 oh a lot of fun uh credit cards
truck
jeep
house
kind of normal yes normal oh you paid
off your house yeah in the 57 000.
wow
wow okay very cool looking at weird
people yeah
okay so you had normal debt yes and and
have been going along how long y'all
been married 24 years okay and you look
up 18 months ago and decided to do this
crazy ramsay stuff what happened um well
actually my mother had given me a book
in 92 when i got my first home and
she's always preached to me about
saving and working as not being in debt
and paying for cash from things and of
course i ignored all of it and had a lot
of fun and running up credit card bills
about about 10 000 in that and
you felt like you didn't have i didn't
have a way out
um you feel trapped you smell you feel
smothered
um but then it uh you started seeing
progress you know and then 18 months ago
you know we
we decided that you know i'm tired of
this and let's let's get out of it we
started following your baby steps and i
was marking off each step we started
with the lowest then kept marking them
off and just visually seeing that
just made a difference for us and then
we printed off your little bricks on the
house where you mark off the bricks
and course that helped us keep going and
and we have two children in college too
so we did all of this while we're paying
for college too
and two others over here wow where are
they in college um one is at utc and one
is at tennessee tech and thankfully they
did the community college thing for two
years
in both affordable schools that they're
in four-year school yeah so you're not
yes you can go crazy on that yeah so
that's good the scholarships have to
offer 1992 your mother gave you one of
my books
the little blue one yeah it has to be
because that's the first the first year
it came out i said that's the one i
won't sign i want one mom give me that's
that's the uh that thing's a classic i
mean
92 is the first year that it came out i
saw those out of the trunk of my car
just like that car over there oh
see that's vintage that's that's
vintage
i'm a slow reader
yeah that are slow on the uptick but
yeah
just took 30 years to get around to it
that's awesome but then okay so what
happened 18 months ago that was the wake
up call that made you get so intense
well i i was really pushing it i'll be
honest and i just wanted him to get on
board with me and uh i would we would
just be very intentional about our
spending and i kind of started doing the
minimalist thing where less is more and
that helped out a whole lot and
it wasn't easy because i had a a bump in
the road i had a stage one breast cancer
diagnosis last year in august so that
kind of set us back a little bit but i
went through the radiation treatments
and we just kept persevering and
we're here now and your cancer-free now
cancer-free now it's been a year
debt-free cancer-free what a year
it was like for us the budget
working on the budget that was probably
the hardest part for me because when you
put it on paper and
you see i mean there was actually
a few years back when the kids were just
born
not just the twins but nolan and katie
i was working she was at home with the
kids and it's a lot of stress and you're
asking for overtime and you're just
trying to break even because at 40 hours
there was a time that
you know 94 a week i was in the hole
at 40 hours a week
and that's a lot of stress on my dad and
a marriage in the home and
it just builds on you and and
as we the past 18 months you see that
light at the end of that tunnel when one
gets paid off you get the credit card
paid off you get the trip to paid off
you get the truck paid off you get and
you just start snowballing just like you
know it's like you teach you know you
see that hope and
it's i didn't know how much stress i
really had
because it had been there for so long
yeah and once you start getting to the
end of it it's like man what can i do i
mean it's like i look at everything
totally different now it's it's
um
what what can i do you know instead of
what i can't do it's like i told my wife
instead of buying on time i want to live
on my time now i don't i don't want i
don't want to
just struggle and i like it and we want
to give god all the glory because and
this none of this would be possible
without him
we definitely put him first in our lives
and
we're here now because of him
yeah we i mean we've been blessed with
with
with health and things that bumps comes
along but it still was still worked out
and uh
again getting to work through a pandemic
no you know i didn't have to worry about
any of that it could still work and
still go and still do and
um it's just been a blessing i mean it's
pretty cool yeah so christy i got to go
back in the story because i i think i'm
missing something here and i want to
make sure i'm catching on what's
happening okay so we go along and about
18 months ago
you somehow connected to us fresh
um i had been listening to you oh you've
been listening for a while for several
years you just kind of turned up the old
heat a little bit in your sweet little
way yes and i was listening to
your daughter too and um okay and you
know oh okay so you just kept turning it
up a little bit turn it up because we
did try this
several years back
and um it just i gave up yeah we weren't
on board and we weren't intentional with
it so we just became intentional and
this still paid off you just felt like
this woman is a force of nature you
realize that
with a smile
pity the kindergartners
look at mike he's he's going through
active recovery right there
yeah it's the truth that is the truth
yeah i could see it hey mike i do want
to ask you because you shared some
really gut-wrenching stuff there and i
think a lot of people feel very all
right what's it like on the other side
and i mean i want you to just now drive
now that you're free i want you to
describe because you said you didn't
know what it felt like because you'd had
it so long so now on the other side what
is the positive emotional and physical
piece that you have you're not trapped i
mean and what i mean by that is i mean i
love my job i mean i've been a toolmaker
all my life i've had in my working life
and you know i've been there since 92
you know for coming up on 30 years but
you feel
um
i don't i don't owe anybody anything you
know i can give
we have some very dear friends you know
lost a daughter to cancer during all
this you know i'm almost well not a year
ago but
and i want to help and i want to help i
want you know if it's just giving
something to saint jude or if it's just
doing i just want to help yeah and and
those opportunities you can you see
you you see somebody that's alone and
at a restaurant i i
i'm not a secrets out i guess now but i
try to i want to buy their lunch and
just let them not know and just go just
the little things you know nothing big
but just
you can just do those things and not
worry you can be a little you're a
little kinder you're a little nicer it's
a little sweeter at home i mean because
i mean the family is growing and and
we're just kind of off and running and
you want to you can step and watch and
you know i i had uh
covered in in august and i missed the
month of work but guess what there was a
savings and i didn't have to worry about
it you know and it's just those types of
things that you see it working
and it's great and it's
yeah and you brought two of your
daughters with you one of their names
christian and kerrigan okay and they're
they're the twins and they're twins okay
how old are they 15. all right
so here comes some more college yeah
but now we're ready we're ready game off
we're ready i'm so proud of y'all
congratulations thank you very well done
what's this house worth you paid off um
probably about 350. yeah awesome
on our way to being baby steps
millionaires then that's nice well
you're right there you're gonna be there
before you know it well done you guys we
got a copy of the legacy journey for you
copy a total money makeover maybe you
can give it away to somebody and they'll
read it before 1992. yes we hope to help
others definitely i love it all right
count it down gang 57 000 paid off in 18
months making 100 a year count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
[Music]
that's gold right there man yeah that is
gold there was so much in that
so much going on that's fun mike might
get in trouble for getting ahead of the
count there he might he might you never
know this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day philippians 3
13 and 14 one thing i do forgetting what
is behind and straining toward what is
ahead i press on toward the goal to win
the prize for which god has called me
heavenward
in christ jesus
serena williams said don't let anyone
work harder than you do
that's important right there guys it's
almost time for christmas it's going to
sneak up on you but for some of you what
should be a time of joy tradition
togetherness
is stress
you're stressing over how you're going
to pay for presents
the big grocery bills
the stuff
doesn't have to be that way
when you have a plan
you have confidence instead of stress
and when everything else seems out of
control financial peace university will
show you how to put that plan in place
you're going to learn step by step how
to get out of debt
save money build wealth be outrageously
generous you put the plan into practice
by budgeting with every dollar it syncs
up easily with your bank you can track
your spending you can finally see where
your money goes you get all of this with
a ramsey plus membership and that's the
only way to get it
you don't have to live through a
stressed out christmas make 2022
the year you start winning because right
now you start a free trial of ramsey
plus plus by texting trial to 33
789 a free trial by texting trial two
three three
seven
eight
nine kevin is in orlando hi kevin
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
so um my wife and i um we have a baby on
the way we just purchased a house
together
i'm trying to decide whether
my previous house which i had paid off
whether i should throw all that at my
mortgage or
invest that you know in the market in
some kind of safe conservative mutual
funds
well uh you're debt free other than the
homes
we have a car payment but just going
gonna pay that off uh once we get the
new money from the house
okay so the the the original house
you're talking about is sold or is going
to be sold
and how much are you going how much are
you going to receive from it
um about 5.50
550 000 clear
yes sir
okay and how much do you owe in your car
um
just under 60 000. and what do you owe
on your home
uh 800 000. and what's your household
income
uh just about 400 000 a year wow way to
go dude what do you guys do for a living
thank you
um we're both in healthcare okay
congratulations very well done great
careers okay
um
well what we have found
is that the first one to five million
dollars of net worth that people get is
typically from a paid for house
and their retirement accounts in 401ks
403 b's iras
our baby step number one is save a
thousand dollars you've obviously done
that two is to be debt free everything
with the house we got a plan to pay off
the sixty thousand dollar car which is
gonna leave us four hundred and ninety
thousand with an eight hundred thousand
dollar mortgage baby step three is
saving three to six months of expenses
how much non-retirement
saving and investing do you currently
have
uh
just under 900 000. non-retirement
yes
mutual sorry um money market account and
uh savings okay
uh what i would do if i woke up in your
shoes is i would pay off my house
100 okay
now you're sitting there with a paid for
house a 400 000 income you have an
emergency fund set aside of three to six
months of expenses
and now there's nothing left to do but
build wealth
and be outrageously generous but no
house payment is gonna get you there and
here's what you're gonna find okay
you're in a high-stress environment
that is emotionally and intellectually
fatiguing agreed
that's correct
you're going to feel something that you
don't anticipate that your intellect
doesn't tell you you're going to feel
when you pay off this house you're going
to feel a release
a sense of peace
because it's like having a backache and
you've had it so long you don't even
realize it's there and you don't think
about it but when it's gone you're like
wow
i just got set free
that's pretty incredible so um that's
what i'm gonna do i'm gonna pay off that
house that's the way i have lived
personally and once i got there it was
fairly easy to become very very wealthy
with that kind of income and not a
payment in the world plus you don't have
a care in the world
in the middle of weirdness and dude
you've experienced some weirdness in
healthcare in the last 24 months agreed
yes sir
yeah and and so one less thing you know
i i have to i've had all kinds of stress
around the business and trying to keep
this thousand people employed and
revenues going up revenues going down
entire areas of revenue disappearing and
trying to run this thing but i never had
the stress of worrying about a
foreclosure i never had the stress of
worrying about if i personally was going
to be left out in the cold because it
was all paid for there's a release there
the borrower's slave to the lender and
when you're 100 debt free there's a
freedom that's going to cause you to
prosper yet even more changes your
decision-making paradigm it really does
and and you're right this at this stage
where they are at this is the right move
it sets them up for their future serious
serious good position you've gotten
yourself into well done
catherine's in london hi catherine
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave hi ken thank you very much for
taking my call and this is my first time
calling in so i'm thrilled to have got
three well we're honored to have you how
can we help
um okay so my question
um
so essentially i'm in a job that i don't
love um
but i have the equivalent of about 20 27
000 worth of debt
that i need to pay off my job is well
paid um
i make about
98 000
equivalent
before tax um then i
i i want out and but then i i've got
this debt that i need to pay i have an
eight-year-old son
he's in private school um that i'm
paying for
and
my question essentially is
how do i plan
an exit from a job that i don't love
yeah well do you like it
okay well a couple things don't walk
into this with the assumption that if
you change jobs that you have to take a
big pay cut and we're not going to jump
off of a cliff here we don't want to see
any interruption in income so catherine
if there's no interruption in income and
you can step into something else that is
much more enjoyable
that doesn't have all the factors at
play that's going on with what's going
on now you wouldn't even be calling us
you'd be like okay and so let's let's
start with the assumption that we're not
going to have an interruption in income
okay that's first but the question is do
you know what you would love to do or is
there a job that you are very intrigued
by a career path that you've always
wanted to pursue
um
to be honest i'm not sure i'm i'm 45
and i kind of feel like
so i work in healthcare and i've worked
in healthcare for 25 years okay um
and i have been looking at other roles
that are within my field but i
am you know
it's um
it's quite a thriving industry at the
moment but every role that i come across
i just i don't even bother to read the
whole
job specs but i'm just not interested
and i just i don't know if it's because
you know if it's a combination of
um
part of the reason why i don't love my
job okay all right so let me know
or the pandemic i kind of feel like i
don't want to do this anymore yeah well
you have to listen to that but here's
what i want you to do
you've got some debt you make really
good money and you've got some debt that
you can pay off
pretty quickly if you stay focused so
for right now catherine i want you to
stay in this job i know you don't love
it i know you want out but let's change
our attitude the attitude is hey i'm
grateful for this job because it's
taking care of me my eight-year-old son
and it's allowing me to pay off debt and
i'm gonna stay put until i've got
something to step into
so that's our focus so here's what i
want to do kelly let's give catherine a
link to the get clear career assessment
that we sell here ramsey solutions
kencoleman.com would you take the
assessment it's going to point out a
whole lot to you that you've never seen
before and then let's come up with a
clear path hang on we're going to give
you the brand new from paycheck to
purpose because it's the field guide to
the mountain that the assessment will
point out both of these tools catherine
will show you the direction that you
need to go walk through it stage by
stage don't interrupt your income and
you're going to be fine
that puts us hour of the ramsey show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you